-♪ Best Friends Challenge ♪
♪ Ooh, yeah ♪
-It works like
"The Newlywed Game,"
okay, but for friends.
I'm going to read you questions
about each other from
the best friends box,
and you will write down --
you will write down --
try to write the same answers.
-By the way, I will put the
apostrophe right there.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Oh, my God.
-Here's --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Someone finished high school.
-Here's the --
[ Light laughter ]
-Okay, I got my answer.
No, I didn't ask a question yet.
Here is the first question.
Okay. "If Martin won
the lottery, what would he buy?"
Martin Short, if he won the
lottery, what would he buy?
Steve, you're writing what
you think Marty would answer.
If Martin won the lottery,
what would he buy?
-Uh-oh.
You have to understand...
-Clearly, you
have different answers.
-...my handwriting --
my handwriting is not so good.
[ Laughter ]
I'm now trying to realize --
remember what I wrote.
-You're writing a book.
-No, you know what?
I was just doing
a sketch of you.
What was the question?
-If Martin won the lottery -- if
Martin won the lottery --
-Okay, I'll go first.
-Okay, Steve, you go first.
-Friends!
-No, hey no.
[ Laughter ]
-Friends?
[ Applause ]
-Wait, wait, wait.
Let me put the apostrophe.
Oh no, there's not.
-I just would put that period.
-There's no -- yeah, exactly.
That period there, perfect.
-And what is the question again?
-"If Martin won the lottery,
what would he buy?"
-Another face-lift, but
this time with a real doctor.
[ Laughter ]
[ Band plays ]
-Already.
[ Applause ]
All right.
This is the next question here.
-Oh, mama!
-Are you ready for this?
Guys?
-What happened?
-It came alive!
-All right, really.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-"If Steve -- if Steve could be
any liquid,
what liquid would he be?
[ Laughter ]
-What liquid?
-Yes.
-That's a --
Who comes up with that?
-It's a deep -- deep question.
If Steve could be any liquid,
what liquid --
-I hope we write the same thing.
-Yeah.
Hey, no!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I'm not sure if
you're best friends right now.
If Steve --
-This is going to prove whether
we are or not, huh, Jimmy?
-Yeah, that's right.
-You don't have the "Chicago
Manual of Style," do you?
Go ahead.
-I didn't bring it with me, no.
It's on my iPhone.
"If Steve could be any liquid,
what liquid would he be?"
Martin, what did you write?
-I wrote skim milk, because he
looks like a glass of skim milk.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Foghorn ]
-Oh, my God.
Oh, God.
You offended Steve!
-Yeah.
I wrote --
I realize this is
just actually bad,
but why would
I want to be a liquid?
-No, that's very interesting.
That's a very
Steve Martin answer.
-I'm on another --
I'm on another plane.
-Yeah, I get it, man.
I get it.
-A dramatic plane.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness.
All right, ready for this?
Marty, "What is the most
embarrassing thing Steve
has ever done?"
-Oh, I know what that is.
-Oh. I know this.
-You both seem to know this one.
"What is the most embarrassing
thing Steve has ever done?"
It's the Best Friends Challenge,
if you're just tuning in
right now.
Martin short and Steve Martin
are seeing if they are
best friends.
-Wow.
-I'm getting a writer's cramp.
-I'm asking them
a serious question.
-Mine is too lengthy.
-I'm asking them
a serious question.
-Do you have another pad?
I've run out of paper.
The Sharpie
never runs out of ink.
Okay, here we go.
"What is the most embarrassing
thing that Steve has ever done?"
Uh --
-Whoops.
-All right.
-Okay.
-Steve, almost there?
-Okay, who goes first?
All right, Martin goes first.
"What is the most embarrassing
thing that Steve has ever done?"
-It was a bad moment.
He slapped Barry Manilow because
he thought Barry was me.
[ Laughter ]
-Did he really?
-♪ Oh, Mandy ♪
-For real, you did that?
-Yes.
-Well --
-In the world of "Late Night."
-Mine is --
-You have to show it to them.
-I'm going to.
[ Laughter ]
-Don't slap him again!
-Have you ever heard of
a thing called timing?
-I'm trying to give you some.
-Oh, okay.
-Got confused in a men's room
and dried my hands
on the man next to me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Foghorn ]
That's perfect.
That was perfect music.
-That was embarrassing.
-All right.
-Let's do one more here.
-Go to hell!
-Let's go.
[ Laughter ]
Let's do one more here.
Complete this sentence.
"Steve has the
world's greatest blank."
Complete this sentence.
"Steve has the
world's greatest blank."
If you're just tuning in,
this is the --
[ Light laughter ]
All right, here we go.
Complete the sentence, "Steve
has the world's greatest blank."
Marty, you wrote?
-The greatest collection
of Nazi memorabilia.
[ Laughter ]
-What's wrong with you, man?
What is wrong with you?
That is absolutely not true.
-All right.
I wrote...
Collection of Nazi memorabilia.
-Oh, my God!
We are best friends!
-Steve Martin, Martin Short.
Check out their
Netflix special on May 25th!